les questions on vous trouve l'info
david jean allard s'est fait voler son
vélo il a reçu une indemnisation de son
assurance mais peu de temps après la
police lui annonce que son vélo volé a
été retrouvé
david s'est demandé est ce que je
devrais retourner à l'assureur le
montant que j'ai reçus en indemnisation
la réponse est oui selon son contrat
c'est l'assureur qui est maintenant le
propriétaire du vélo retrouver si david
veut le garder il doit le racheter
eh oui et s'il était tenté de garder le
vélo et l'argent il ne respecterait pas
son contrat selon le bureau d'assurance
du canada
ce serait alors considéré comme de la
fraude et gare à vous si l'assureur
venait en être avisé
ce serait quand même dommage qu'au final
ce soit vous considère comme le voleur
s'il veut garder son pont vieux vélo
david peut rembourser le montant de
l'indemnisation à l'assureur
l'avantagent sa réclamation seront
effacés plus rien ne figurera dans son
dossier passez le mot couple
[Musique]